let's go to part 2 of this memo of of
James comb written by James Comey after
his February oval office meeting with
President Donald Trump I already
discussed that this memo which has been
revealed by the New York Times to exist
indicates that Donald Trump allegedly
asked fired FBI director James Comey to
end the investigation into Michael Flynn
there is another aspect of that memo
that is such a blockbuster that I didn't
want it to get hidden by mentioning it
quickly in the other segment ok during
the same meeting according to the Comey
memo about the meeting Trump asked James
Comey to start imprisoning journalists
who publish classified information let
that sink in for a second here is a
quote that we have about this mr. Comey
had been in the Oval Office that day
with other senior national security
officials for a terrorism threat
briefing when the meeting ended mr.
Trump told those present including mr.
Pence and attorney general Jeff Sessions
to leave the room except for mr. Comey
alone in the Oval Office mr. Trump began
the discussion by condemning leaks to
the news media saying that mr. Comey
should consider putting reporters in
prison for publishing classified
information according to one of mr.
commis associates let's parse this out
by asking James Comey to end an
investigation into Michael Flynn Donald
Trump is being like a dictator
attempting to interfere with the
Independence of the Justice Department
right the process of law enforcement by
asking James Comey to imprison
journalists who publish classified
information we are talking about an
attempt to stifle press freedom and
independence to be super clear if you
leak secret information as the
individual who obtained that information
you're talking about Chelsea Manning
you're talking about Edward Snowden etc
that is a crime you can be charged
prosecuted and imprisoned for that
interesting to mention Chelsea Manning
on the day that she is being released
from prison based on President Obama
having commuted her sentence
historically it has not been the law
that you imprison journalists or media
outlets for publishing classified
information that they have received but
not obtained themselves imagine that
there is someone in the military who
steals some classified information they
have committed a crime if they bring
that information to me and I publish
that information historically the way
this has worked in the United States for
a very very long time I have not
committed any crime by publishing that
information because I didn't steal that
information I received that information
I didn't ask for it to be stolen etc
what Donald Trump asked James Comey for
in the Oval Office allegedly would be a
historic war on the press we're talking
about reporting on classified
information which is a bedrock right of
journalists and Donald Trump is saying
put him in jail put him in prison for
something that is not against the law he
continues to push the envelope with what
he can get away with and it comes to
berating the media yeah before he would
just out members of the media at its big
rallies or I'll go to veteran being
around against them yeah and then he
started to you know called
news that he disagrees with fake news
yes indeed this is the latest chapter
and this is perhaps worse because if
this was to happen it would be a direct
infringement on the First Amendment
right to a free press this is a stuff of
dictators oh that there is no way to
parse it any other way at this point in
time this is crossing a line
no one regardless of political party or
political orientation should stand by
while this type of request is being made
by the president look at the countries
where journalists are jailed and
imprisoned this is what Donald Trump not
only wants and some amorphous son's not
offhandedly said during a campaign rally
as president of the United States
according to this memo he asked the FBI
director to go and make it happen
and the press is literally being
targeted yesterday we had on the program
dan Hyman yeah who was arrested for
asking Health and Human Services
Secretary Tom Price a question perhaps
in an aggressive form he was too loud
she shouted the question and ended up
getting himself arrested we did do that
story yesterday check out that interview
if this is not a red line for
even trumpets I don't know what is and
I'm increasingly agreeing with Donald
Trump when he said I could shoot people
on Fifth Avenue and I wouldn't lose my
supporters he is attacking freedom of
the press by saying imprisoned
journalists who have broken no laws and
and yet we are not hearing much from
trumpets on this are there any red lines
left to be crossed I think it would be
public executions of American citizens I
don't know what's left send me your
thoughts about this I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman you can follow the show on
twitter at david pakman show